Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
Ah, there you go, see,
we built it up so much--
about life for a long time.
I technically didn't mess it up.
I just paused in the middle.
Yeah. You kinda
had a burst.
I just stopped.
And I picked it up.
I'm Rhett.
and I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of not as dim lighting
in our secondary, but special location
we're gonna talk about the questions
that keep you up at night.
That was the prompt that we
put out there into the world.
You know, we put these
prompts out into the world,
on our Twitter feed, follow
us on Twitter @mythical.
Twitter feed.
If you wanna see what these things are,
if you wanna be a part of
it, if you want to hear
us say your Twitter handle and then rip
your contribution to shreds or not--
That's not gonna happen,
it never happens.
super appreciative.
I'm going to lodge you with praise.
So we go, we go through these things--
For your thoughts.
You know, we'll come up with these prompts
or Kiko or Jacob will help us
come up with these prompts.
Sometimes things that
might lead to discussion,
we have no clue what people are gonna say.
And then we're, you know--
No, I do, link.
We sift through it.
I've been a student of the
internet for so many years.
I know exactly what kind of
responses we're going to get.
Well, did you know that the responses to
what question keeps you up at
night could be pretty heavy.
Yeah.
I mean, we live in heavy times.
Yeah. And then once we
were going through them,
I think we just had a different,
we had a different vibe.
Who was that, rapper?
We didn't pick the--
Who was the rapper?
The heaviest ones.
This conversation we're
gonna to keep it light.
What was the rapper that had, Heavy?
It was a--
Heavy D?
Heavy D
Heavy D and the Boys.
Heavy D heavy--
I think there was a Z--
Heavy times would be like the perfect
comeback album for Heavy D right now.
He is dead.
Oh, That'd be quite a comeback!
That'd be--
Yeah, that would also,
if someone has died and
then they make a new album,
"Quite a Comeback" is a good one.
Of course there's
a lot of people
putting out post-humus albums,
Yeah, people think Tupac's still alive.
I know, well, I mean, what do you think
of the new Pop Smoke?
I've heard, I've heard my
son talking about this.
I can't say I've partaken.
I only know one Pop Smoke song.
I mean, if someone's dead,
I don't really wanna get into them.
Lincoln was a huge fan of
Juice World before he died.
And then it's just, it's
so sad now, you know,
I thought you said you
didn't want to be heavy.
You're did!
I was talking about Heavy D coming back
and you said he was dead.
You coulda lied to me.
You could have said, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's back.
What was that Heavy D song?
What was the song?
He had like song or two,
you know, it wasn't great.
He had a, his voice was
kind of like his voice,
he kind of had a newscaster voice.
It was interesting.
Huh?
The way that he rapped, you got an,
he had a newscaster, kinda--
Never thought of it like that.
Kind of lilt to his voice.
I have something that I
need to catch you up on,
you and you--
Do it.
So some of you who may
follow me closely on,
on the Twitter, or even follow my wife
closely on the Twitter,
know that we tend to get into
these little back and forth
and sometimes she'll take a picture of me
doing something stupid or whatever.
And a couple of weeks ago,
it may be a few weeks ago.
By this point, she took a
picture of me with a feline,
which is the technical term for a cat.
Now you might know that I
typically, I'm not fond of cats.
I was one hypnotized to try to like cats.
And I couldn't.
I tried, I gave it the old college try
and I have stated clearly
that I don't hate cats,
I just strongly prefer dogs, right?
Lots of theories about why this is.
I think you've even said that,
so the times when you
assert your hate for cats--
It's kind of a "bit."
It's a, it's a comedic assertion.
Yeah.
It's fine.
It's based, it's one of those things that,
it's based in the truth
that I prefer dogs.
It's a heightened degree.
I wouldn't, you know,
I would not own a cat
or have a cat as a pet.
If you don't like the
term, "own" for pets.
And some people have been like,
people who don't like cats
are full of themselves.
They want somebody to worship them.
They're afraid of rejection,
maybe all that's true.
I don't know.
But I do prefer dogs more.
However, my wife and I've
been taking a lot of walks
during the COVID and I
don't know, six weeks ago?
Walking past this house that
we have walked past many times
and a, what do you call the cat
that's like an orange
striped cat, Garfield?
I thought that was a Tabby cat.
I don't know. I'm not a cat expert.
I don't know much about--
Let's just call it a Garfield-like cat,
makes a beeline for us as
we're passing this house.
Okay. Like coming at us hard.
And at first I was a little bit like,
when a cat's coming at you hard, I mean,
somebody like me who's not
typically scared of animals.
It's like, what's this guy gonna to do?
What is it called? Orange cat breed.
It is what you have is what I've seen.
What breed are orange cats?
Tabby
Orange Tabby.
You're were right.
Persian munchkin, American
bobtail, British short hair,
Bingle, Maine Coon, Abyssinian.
An Egyptian Mau--
It was like that.
It was like your classic short haired.
That one right there, that's it!
Yeah. It was like the cat
I had as a child, Thomas,
who only came to my house
Thomas?
and visited me in the shed out back
whenever he felt like it.
Hmm.
So anyway, this Tabby cat approaches us
and begins to Meow loudly.
And again, not being a cat expert.
I don't know exactly what this means,
but he does not seem to
be aggressive at all.
And then he proceeds to--
At both of you or just you?
Both of us.
Then he proceeds to do that thing
where cats rub up against your leg.
Okay.
Ostensibly to say, "Hey, I like you."
"I love you."
And this doesn't happen
often with cats and me
or cats and people that I knew of.
Hm mm.
And, but I'm immediately
sort of into this cat.
I mean, I gotta be honest.
Oh!
Yeah.
Right there on the street.
And again, this probably,
fits perfectly the theory
that people who want to
be worshiped and loved
and are afraid of rejection like dogs more
and if you can find a cat that's doglike
and wants to love you, worship
you and not reject you,
then you feel what, you love the cat back.
That's me.
I'm shallow.
So this cat--
I wasn't gonna say it.
Is really, is really going at my legs,
really begins to have an affinity for me.
I get down on my knees.
Were you wearing shorts or pants?
I don't walk in pants.
Were you're wearing, like,
we were in that carpet suit
from way back in the day that we have?
Nope, just my straight carpety legs,
were the things that
this cat was rubbing on
and my wife got a picture with it.
Not a great picture.
It was dark.
I was looking down, but
she posted it on Twitter.
And I said more to come.
I actually, I think I
tweeted something like,
"Breaking news. I have found
a cat that I think I like,"
or something like that.
I did see that.
So let me just tell you
that we began to really,
I began to always want
to walk past this house.
Oh, a tryst.
And this cat, seven out of
10 times would be there,
no identifying marks, other
than it's what it looks like.
No leash--
No collar.
Okay
No leash,
of course it wasn't
carrying a leash, no collar.
And it would just come out into the road.
And I mean,
But it would always
come from that house, even
though it didn't have a--
Always come from that house,
like he would be in that
front yard of that house.
Sometimes he would be sitting
on the steps and also--
People feed feral cats.
When we walked with Barbara,
it would come up to Barbara
like, "Hello friend,--
Seriously?
on four legs."
And Barbara, you know how Barbara reacted
to that cat in the video,
Barbara was indifferent
towards this cat, but did
not growl did not hiss
didn't do anything.
Wow, there!
It didn't bark--
Neutral territory
not not your home, that's what people
are saying in the comments.
And I began to really like this cat
and I actually began
to think things like--
I'ma steal this cat?
Well, I thought that a little bit.
I wasn't gonna admit that.
No one would know.
I started to think, I
think I could have a cat.
Boy, wouldn't that send
waves to the internet.
I mean, maybe I think a
little too highly of myself--
Hmm?
But at least through the fandom,
It would send a ripple through
a subset of our fandom.
Right.
And so, and then one time, the last time,
most recent time I saw the cat,
Jesse and I are walking.
He comes up, he does this thing.
I pet him.
He's purring, he's meowing.
And then we start walking and he's like,
"I'm gonna to walk with you guys,"
just starts walking with us.
Oh.
Walks, a full block.
And at that point, I'm like,
do you really wanna keep walking with us?
But I mean, this is a four mile walk, bud.
And he seemed to understand English
and he sorta slowed down, turn around.
But I started to think
this is, we live, you know,
there's coyotes around, you know?
And I've seen, in our old house--
Coyote will get a cat.
I once found--
Or a little dog.
I think I told this story on
Ear Biscuit in times gone by,
I found a half a cat, just a half a cat
in my front yard one time.
Hmm, yeah.
Right. So that's what coyotes
do to cat. They take half.
Hey, you were halfway
there, way back then,
you just didn't know it.
They take half, they leave half.
You're a cat lover.
You know,
And so I was worried--
I love cats,
but I love them in their whole form.
Especially, and it was just
the back half of the cat,
which--
Yeah, I remember.
The coyote takes the interesting part.
So I was worried about this cat.
I was like, you just can't
be befriending everyone.
Look at you with
emotions, towards the cat!
You can't just go up to dogs and people,
you can't just trust people.
I felt I had like a fatherly
instinct to be like,
let me, you need to watch videos
about strangers and vans and stuff.
So carry a picture of a coyote
next time you walking past.
Just the other night.
Oh no.
Is this bad?
Jesse and I are walking.
Getting ready to get up to the house,
get to the house on the
post in front of the house,
there is a sign.
What?
It is a picture of my friend.
And it says lost cat.
You stole the cat.
I did not steal the damn cat.
The cat is gone.
Oh no.
And, uh--
Both halves?
I'm assuming.
The cat's gone.
And then I, then on the rest of our walk--
The cat didn't have a collar.
The cat didn't have a collar!
I noticed--
Did people make--
Other signs--
A sign for a cat?
If you care enough to make
a sign when the cat is gone,
you should care enough
to give the cat a collar
before it's gone.
I just think this cat
didn't need a collar.
But anyway, there's other signs
all throughout the neighborhood.
Dang.
And I was just like, what does this mean?
I don't really believe that the universe
is telling me things, but I
do find it somewhat helpful
to just assume the universe
is telling me things.
I find that a useful way to live.
If God, I'm gonna to say, God--
Sure. I think that's interchangeable--.
is gonna tell you something.
I think that's interchangeable
with the term "Universe."
For you?
Then he's gonna tell you something.
I hope it's gonna be, not about a cat.
Well, I mean--
If the universe is telling
you something, what is it?
And why is this about you?
I'm just, well, because I'm--
Somebody lost a poor cat.
I'm interacting with this cat, so--
Okay.
In my world and my point of reference--
I need to understand,
that's a weird question to ask.
I'm just messing with you.
I'm trying to figure out how
I should interpret this sign.
You know, I was moving towards a cat.
I was opening my heart towards a cat.
I was enjoying time with cat.
And...
And, and now cat has gone.
Cat was taken from you.
And listen, I listen, I
feel for these people,
but that cat is dead.
I mean, I interacted
with that cat long enough
to know that that cat in our neighborhood,
that cat is not around anymore.
You thought, but--
I mean, maybe somebody did steal it--
You did say, for a second.
You thought, I'd like,
I wouldn't like a cat.
I would like this cat.
And I will, in one time,
Barbara got out of our house,
you know the story she, she
literally, somebody stopped
and saw her walking down the street.
They opened the door and she
jumped in the car with them.
That is the kind of dog that Barbara is.
And that's the kind of
cat that this cat was.
So it's a lover.
It's not a fighter.
And so it will, it tried to love a coyote.
And I think the coyote gave it
a special kind of love back.
Again the collar thing
reduces the level of sympathy.
But I do know that there
are people who will feed
feral cats and they will consider it,
they will have a relationship with them,
but they won't--
Well yeah--
Let them in the house, they won't--
This is clearly that kind of relationship.
Yeah, we had a guy who was
moving out of our neighborhood,
who was friends with
Christie, through the gym
she used to go to and he was like, listen,
I know you guys live near
me, a couple of streets
down the hill.
This is an odd request, but we're moving.
Do you want our cat?
Would you--
Would you feed our cat?
Yeah. Would you take care of our cat?
Cause it's a, it's a feral cat.
It just, it runs through the neighborhood,
but we feed it and she
shows up every morning
and I wanna bring her to your house
and have you feed her and have her
start showing up at your door?
Like he was really
concerned about this cat.
Hmm. You said no?
And I guess, you know, you
can't have it both ways.
I would think it would
be weird if that cat,
a feral cat, who you just happened to feed
and have a relationship
with, when it goes missing,
you would put up signs to then what?
Bring it back so you--
So it will come back.
But it goes off, it's a free cat.
That cat--
Well, hold on.
The short life it lives--
I'm not a cat expert--
Was a full life, man.
I'm not a cat expert, but I--
That cat!
I tend to believe,
that feral cats in the,
in the traditional sense
are not as people, they
don't come up to people--
That is strange, yeah.
And meow--
Yeah, that's strange.
And rub on them, this is a house cat.
This is a cat that has it both ways.
This is a cat that gets whatever it wants.
This cat definitely was on
the inside and the outside.
And you know what?
This is like a cat in a halfway house.
You know what I'm saying?
I think we can celebrate the cat's life.
And we don't have to feel sad because--
Halfway house that is a--
That cat had it all.
Half. He's in half right now.
That cat everyone, it met.
It just, it just showered with love.
I mean, no offense to you.
I don't think you were special--
It lived a full life.
In that sense.
No, it ended up, it ended up developing
a special bond with me.
You were a giant dude walking a dog.
If it came up to you, that
cat would come up to anything.
You're right.
It would come out to a coyote.
My dog does the same thing.
My dog has no loyalty to
me and I still love it.
My dog would have gone home
and just started a new life
with that other family.
I know it for a fact.
So you--
Never thought about us again.
Okay, well maybe that
cat, did you name it?
It has a name.
And it's on the sign, but I
didn't wanna say it because--
I don't want to--
Oh!
You know, I don't like people
making connections with it.
It had a name, but it
didn't have a collar.
With the neighborhood
and that kinda thing.
It still doesn't add up.
I don't think I'm missing anything, am I?
It's just doesn't
I think it's pretty simple.
You gonna post signs when it's gone,
you need to give it a
collar before it leaves.
Yeah.
I think the cat is just, was a loose,
they were holding onto
this cat very loosely
and they lost grip.
But for you the cat was
an angel leading you
to the love of the feline.
I didn't know where the
relationship was going,
but it was going places very fast.
And I was just letting my heart.
just take flight.
I wasn't--
It ended all too soon.
I was rerouting my path to this house.
I was spending quality time with the cat.
I was getting pictures with the cat.
Hmm--
Are you okay? I don't
wanna gloss over that.
I don't think I'm okay.
Because I don't think I'll
find another cat like this.
You won't.
I know for a fact,
I mean, first of all,
if you don't like kittens,
you don't have a heart.
You're not human if
you don't like kittens,
like no-one's like, kittens suck. Right?
Kittens are awesome. I
got to have a kitten.
But the chances that the kitten
turns into a regular cat,
Pretty high.
So high.
And at that point it's like
I'm not interested anymore.
I want the animal to love me.
I'm getting emotional
support from this animal.
I mean, when I do my
stretches in the morning
and Barbara gets on me.
I need that. I become dependent upon that.
You know what I'm saying?
When Barbara leaves or Barbara dies--
Hmm.
She will be replaced
potentially with a clone of her
or probably just another dog.
A lot of responses to our
prompt of what question
keeps you up at night,
were related to dogs.
They were, a lot of people
are kept up at night thinking,
what does their dog think of them?
Hmm.
No one thinks about what
their cat thinks of them.
Cause I think--
They know.
Right.
We already talked about
that on an Ear Biscuit
so for all of you, who...
Did we not devote an
entire Ear Biscuit to this?
To what your dog is thinking?
Yes.
I think that was what we call--
Somebody recently--
A rabbit hole episode.
You guys--
So look back, look back
through that if you really
wanted us to discuss that,
because we're not hitting on that today.
Somebody recently said
because it is happening
so regularly now that
we've got so many episodes
of Ear Biscuits so many episodes
of Good Mythical Morning
and Good Mythical MORE
that we will have a
conversation about something--
The bidet conversation!
And we're like blown away.
Yeah. We talked about the
bidets last week or week before,
whatever they were like,
guys, you did a whole episode
on GMM where you highlighted this product.
You really do forget an episode
as soon as it's done, don't you?
And the fact is there's just so many.
Yeah.
Yes, I forgot.
I saw that.
I knew that they existed, but I didn't,
you know, it, they didn't
exist in my accessible world.
Well, the interesting thing about that,
because the memory did
flood back when I saw
the little segments from the show,
we were wearing fake butts
and we were testing strange--
Ah, yeah.
Butt products and one of
them was a portable bidet.
And it was different
than the one that I got.
Did you look at it?
Is it--
No, I didn't watch it.
You didn't see the picture?
Mine's in the bathroom in there.
I got it here.
It's like a teal color and
it's got a longer wand on it.
And the wand doesn't fold down.
Oh, my wand folds.
Okay. I'm pretty sure
the wand doesn't fold.
How does the wand not fold?
What happens then?
It's just, don't squeeze it
until you're ready, I think.
Okay.
So here we were squeezing this thing
on each other's fake butts over our pants,
which had our real butts underneath.
And we were just talking
about how, I mean, the sin...
I didn't watch it, it was a GIF.
So it wasn't anything to listen to,
but we were just talking
about how strange it was
an oh, how we have changed.
Oh yeah, we love it now.
As we said, get on the train, we did it.
And we don't even remember
when we thought it was weird.
That's how revolutionary...
This is two episodes ago because I...
Yeah.
Well, cause the other thing
people pointed out was--
That's how much it can impact your rectum.
Our conversation--
And your life.
About Tao.
Yeah, that was another one.
It's someone was like, guys--
Give context--
On Good Mythical Morning a few weeks ago,
we did a thing where we
tried a bunch of different--
Levels of Chinese food--
From, super inexpensive
Frozen.
To super expensive and the
super expensive restaurant
that we got the food from was called Tao.
And I talked about how I went
to my friend's birthday party.
They were super fancy whatever.
And Link was like, why didn't I go?
And I put you on a guilt trip.
And I said--
I said, why didn't I go?
At the time, I didn't remember.
So I figured that you were invited,
but I thought it would be funny to act
as if you weren't invited.
So we had that conversation.
People were like,
it's funny how often people get,
try to read so many things into the things
that we say to each other.
I love it though, that's
why I'll feed into it.
But they were like, "Link is really upset
about not getting invited to Tao."
Yeah, I was so upset.
You were at, he was invited to Tao.
He couldn't go for some reason.
The irony--
It was 2017.
Yeah. Oh, that was deep.
A long time ago.
So many years ago.
The irony of my joke is
that I know it elicits
that response, but the joke is predicated
on some people's assumption
that whenever one of us
does anything that the other person
should always be invited.
Like we're always there.
Well, it's like when
people find us in public
and they say, "Where's Link?".
I'm like, "I don't know."
Find us in public fine. Yeah, or..
Either one of us.
Right. They ask where the other guy is.
It's like, I could be anywhere
in the world--
We can do things--
And that 90% of the time,
if I'm by myself, it's like,
"Where's Link?"
I don't know.
I don't track him.
You know what I'm saying?
But we are together a lot and every time
they see us we're together.
So they just assume that must
be the way that they exist.
We are together a lot.
Yeah.
But I've never been to Tao.
And we totally forgot that
we had that conversation,
which at that time you were
like, you were invited.
And I was like, yeah,
Christie was invited,
but then she forgot to tell me,
and then she forgot about it.
And we made other plans.
But do you know, think
about how impossible it is,
it would be to have a
brain that could access
all your memories, but
also at the same time
access the venue at which you access
those memories publicly.
We've had so many
conversations on Ear Biscuits,
on Good Mythical Morning, et cetera.
But we've also had a lot of
conversations just in life,
amongst friends with
just the two of us here,
and that part of the
brain that would be able
to catalog every single
memory and also attach
a little flag to it that
says that conversation
happened on Ear Biscuits.
Nobody except a very
advanced yet to be invented,
artificial intelligence
could be able to do that.
But we have it.
We have a brain extension
and it is the mythical beast.
Right. That's true.
Fandom.
That remembers these things because
of all of them out there that are talking
on the Mythical Society
that are talking on Reddit--
Yeah, it's a talking base, for sure.
They're accessing, binge watching
and just having this,
it's very fresh to them.
And they can remember it
because if they hear us talk
about something and they've
heard us talk about it before,
it's easy to remember that.
I've heard that story about
the Chinese restaurant before.
Because they don't have to know exactly
where it took place even
though this person who found it
did know exactly and then cut it out but--
I do think that, and it's changed how
we talk about things
because we've come to grips
with this reality slowly over time.
I don't know exactly
how you feel about it,
but I know that I am
overly sensitive to it.
Even like I made a comment
after our last Ear Biscuit,
I was like, you know, I'm not happy with,
I don't like referring the
stories that we've already told
or retelling stories
that, and you're like,
hey, people like that,
because it gives them a sense
of if you're referring to
something that they missed,
it's like, hey, I should
have been listening earlier.
I should have been, I should
have been a part of this
in every new thing we
talk about is something
that then can be a reference point later
because it's part of our lives.
And even if we forget it,
you can help us with it.
But--
If they remember it, then they feel like
they're a part of something,
they've been around.
So I think the way that this
phenomenon has impacted us,
or at least one way is
we kind of own the fact
that we do things for comedic effect that,
and it seems it doesn't
denigrate our sincerity,
but it's, it's just strange dance
that for the longest time, we would just,
we told the stories, we put it out there
and then you tell the stories later
and they're a little bit different
or they morph or whatever
and we talk about
how memory changes and we
give ourselves the excuse,
but basically there's
also this, like you said,
about the cat thing.
Years ago, we wouldn't talk
about the cat thing in that way.
And I think that's part of the phenomenon
of the constant communication
with our listeners
is that they know us better
than we know ourselves sometimes.
And so, hey, it's like,
oh, we just said that
for comedic effect or, you
know what, we forgot that.
So I filled in the gap with something
a little bit different
or whatever the case may be.
Or there was an example of
the, I don't know if it was,
I think it was the wired
autocomplete interview that we did.
And all the comments are, basically,
we were in one of those weird moods
where it's early in the
morning in New York City.
And we did that interview
and we usually take a super,
sarcastic tone when, when it comes to any
of that sort of those interviews
that are done in that way.
Cause we're just here to be funny, right.
And we almost get so committed to sarcasm
that we make a mockery of the whole thing.
And so people who watch the comments are,
"I don't think they
told any truth in this."
"I think that they were
joking the whole time."
And then if you don't
know us, the tone switch
between being sarcastic
and being truthful,
especially for me, there is
none, there is no tone switch.
It's exactly the same.
You just have to, you
have to be on your toes.
But there's a little tweak.
There's a twinkle in the eye.
Yeah. You=
But you gotta really know it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but usually it's the
context of what I'm saying
is how you know, whether or not it's true.
And then sometimes I'll
watch something back
and I'll be like, yeah, I seem
serious there, but I wasn't.
I get it. If you thought
I was serious there,
I don't blame you.
So I don't know.
But now we're just turning this
into a self-analysis podcast.
But we do that too much.
Let's just announce it.
Let's analyze other people's brains.
And what keeps you up at night.
But first we don't have them with us.
And this is one of the
disadvantages to recording here
at our secondary location.
But we got a new product.
We're always doing things that are just,
we're trying to do
things to mix things up.
We got something called the
color changing mythic cups.
We got it's a four pack of plastic cups
that when you put cold beverages into them
or just liquids, you could put
poison as liquids into them.
Just don't drink it.
It will change color.
Change color.
I mean, we sell the only cups
on the planet that do this.
It's a proprietary science
that we have we've monopolized.
Now see, that was an example of sarcasm.
I'm sure there's other cups that do it,
but they probably look stupid
and they're not related to us.
So buy ours
And that was truthful.
mythical.com.
There's other things besides cups as well.
We're actually--
Sip your boys!
We're actually thinking
about selling a cup
for a baseball player as
well, that changes color
when it gets hit with a ball.
Did I just get hit with a ball? Yup.
Or it changes color when
you put your balls in it.
Are my balls in this thing? Yup.
There it is, it's red.
Okay.
It's gonna be red.
Well, it can be any color you want.
Let's start with a question
from, look at this--
Why don't a cup--
Yep.
You know how you got truck nuts?
Have a fake pair of nuts.
Have a, sports cup shaped like big nuts.
Like, were you whispering to yourself?
I'm thinking out loud. What?
I wanna, wear a cup next
time I play baseball
that the actual shape of the
cup is two, it's got two, two--
Two places for nuts?
Two bulbs. It's the double bulbed--
Well, in order to have a double bulb,
but you've got to have
a ridge in the middle
and now you've got a ridge in
the middle of your scrotum,
which is not something anybody wants.
Not everybody's nuts hang the same way.
Not all everybody's
nuts are the same size.
Why are we talking about this?
Because I think there's
white space in the cup world.
The cup vertical.
I think we can definitely
wedge into the cup world.
Yeah, and--
And Rhett and Link cups
available at mythical.com.
It's where the cup is shaped
like nuts, truck nuts.
And maybe we got some
that are just one nut
because some people got one nut.
Some people got three nuts.
Well they need to get together.
So you can average out--
some sort of
foreign exchange situation.
Okay.
First question is from Caleb W. Francis.
We're big fans of Caleb. He a--
Funny, funny, funny guy!
We got him on TikTok and
now we follow each other
on social medias of different sorts.
He's got a question.
He went to the beach.
I've been following his Instagram stories.
I think he took like a full
cross country trip apparently.
Oh. I saw him on a beach.
The beach at one point, he got to a beach.
Why do we only get two sets of teeth?
The first set only lasts
like five to six years.
And the second set is supposed to last
a possible 90 plus years.
Hmm.
Seems like we could use
more sets of backup teeth.
Oh, now Caleb, thank you for responding.
You know, you're a public comedian,
you know it, you gotta,
there's this moment
when it's like, okay, am I gonna respond
to somebody, some other creator's prompt?
It's like, okay.
If he considers himself just a fan
and he respond in that way,
then as a mythical beast,
boy, that makes me feel good Caleb.
I'm glad you're in the fold.
And if you did it just
because for other reasons,
I'm glad he did anyway.
You know what I'm saying is
if you still wanna use this
teeth- bit as a funny TikTok--
You should--
Still do it.
Right.
You know,
In fact it may even be cool for people
who connected to.
Yeah. See if you can do that.
Now, this is a great question.
Two things come to mind for me.
The first thing you
know, you've heard this,
you know that elephants
have a certain set of teeth,
number of sets of teeth.
And then when the final
set wears out, they die.
And that's how they know
they're supposed to die.
My teeth are gone and that's
not actually how it worked,
I just can't eat anymore.
But the second thing that I think about
is I often think about
when people get their teeth
knocked out in a sports hockey, whatever,
just maybe an accident
with a Weed Whacker,
it happens, right?
Yeah.
And the only thing I'm thinking about
when somebody gets their
teeth knocked out as an adult,
I'm like, that's it, those
teeth are gone forever.
Like now that you're gonna have some
kind of denture situation.
Uh, huh?
Now it's one thing if you get
dentures, when you get old,
but when you're like 22 and you get
your front teeth knocked
out, it's like, damn,
you got to get dentures now, right.
I mean, maybe they got
some sort of technology.
They're pretty good at that though.
Yeah. I don't think it ends up being
that big of a deal now.
But think about the old days,
let's go back before modern dentistry.
Poor wooden teeth.
Wooden teeth, man.
But even before that, let's go back to--
Get people's teeth--
Let's go back to like the cave people.
Think about how devastating it would be.
Like you get into a fight and you're like,
I'm gonna punch you in the face.
It's gonna break your front teeth.
And so for the rest of
your life, on this earth,
you can't bite a turkey leg.
Well, not if you only knock a couple out.
You can still bite a--
You can't bite it in the same way.
You're gonna be a side biter.
And if you got a little mouth like me,
side biting is difficult.
I don't want--
I think you should have backup teeth.
I mean, I don't know how
many teeth Caleb has lost.
It seems like he might've
lost some adult teeth.
I think they're wearing down.
I see a lot of old people.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not about wear and tear for humans
as much as it's just about--
It would be nice to, what
if it happened like a shark.
They just kind of lining up
like in a Coliseum to drop down.
You know, I am not with
you on this one, Caleb
because if there's anything
I hated in childhood,
it was getting my toenails cut.
But if it was anything
else, it was a losing teeth.
Man, losing teeth was
like pulling teeth for me.
It's horrible.
My aunt Vicky, I went over to her house
I would let the tooth just
rot out and it would just,
it would have to fall out on its own.
Yikes.
But she would get antsy and she would say,
"Come over here and I'm gonna wrap it up
in a Kleenex and yank it out."
This is where being an only child
gave you a disadvantage in this area.
When you have siblings,
they do things like
tie your tooth up to a three-wheeler,
you know what I'm saying?
That happened to you?
No, but that's an exaggerated form
of the kind of things that happen, you--
Did Cole do something to you?
I don't have any specific memories.
I have more like I've watched
this happen on the internet
type memories and I'm sure that
we did something like that.
Did you enjoy pulling your own teeth?
I enjoyed right after it was pulled.
Because it's annoying for it to be loose?
Yeah.
It's like having this
weird thing in your mouth
and you're like, I gotta
get rid of this thing.
Like a jostly, hanging rock?
There's a sense of euphoria
when it comes out and then--
I never experienced that.
After it comes out. It's
like, oh, that didn't hurt.
You know what I'm saying? It's like--
But it's, it's bloody and
it's fleshy under there.
And the color of that
pulpy flesh is just gross.
Don't look at it. It's
in your, you have to
really make an effort.
And then, then a few hours
later you gotta eat something.
This is why I still have my
wisdom teeth, by the way,
you know what I should have
had those pulled decades ago.
Well, you don't need
to worry about it now.
And now it's like as long
as you keep them clean.
So I, I try really hard, but I don't.
If I had to look, if it
wasn't like, Oh, you know,
middle-aged, about to get my
old man teeth, they're wider.
And so for every two you lose,
you get one in its place or
something interesting like that.
I don't know. It'd be
something to look forward to.
But the losing thing, even at this age,
I've never pulled any
of my children's teeth.
I can't believe that Lando,
he would get so annoyed with them.
He would, pull them out.
He worked up a lot more courage
than a normal child's behavior.
But Lando's a lot like me
at that age, there was,
there was a lot of just nervousness.
Right? So aren't you a little
surprised that he's just,
yanked it out?
Yeah.
So I'm proud of the guy.
But it's because he's
got brothers and sisters,
even just the presence of,
of siblings has an impact
on that kind of thing.
That's my theory.
But I don't think you're
talking about pulling teeth--
I talk--
And the tooth fairy--
The tooth fairy would sometimes wait
over a week to come and
get that tooth from him.
The tooth fairy doesn't visit our house.
I don't know if he knows where we live.
I think this is more, this situation
that I'm getting at,
which is you accidentally
lose a tooth for some reason, right?
I certainly hope this doesn't happen to me
in my adult life, but it could.
Wow. You really fear this?
I would say I have a rational fear
of getting my teeth knocked out.
First of all, just whatever
happens that you get--
Does it break off or does
the root come out too?
Depends on the nature of it, man.
Gosh.
I'm thankful that we live in modern times
and it will be a relatively easy thing.
And I've got plenty of
friends who were like,
oh yeah, these whole half of my top teeth
are fake or something like that.
And you know, I didn't have no idea,
but it's interesting
because evolution has,
doesn't have an awareness of
any modern technology, right?
So evolution is just happening--
Blind
Blindly and based on people's environments
and adaptations and so
for whatever reason,
it was not seen as advantageous
to have another set of teeth.
But you have to know that lots
of people are losing teeth.
And now in the modern world with sugar,
basically just sugar, you got tooth decay
that also evolution was
never prepared for, right?
So you've got like certain cultures
that are living in the
Amazon and all of a sudden
they're introduced to modern foods.
And then they're just
teeth start falling out
because they have not
coupled eating sugary foods
with modern dental hygiene.
Hmm.
You got to have both of those together.
And even sometimes if you do,
if you don't do a good job
cleaning those wisdom teeth,
they're gonna have to
pull 'em out someday.
So I don't know, I don't really understand
why we don't have the backup teeth,
but it was just determined to not
be worth the genetic effort.
I'm so thankful for that.
The thing about wisdom
teeth is you pull those out
and they don't wanna come out.
That's what's been so scary for me.
All these years.
Yeah.
My father in law pulled
mine because he's a dentist.
And, and he just has a wanton desire
to yank something that--
He loves it.
That is perfectly
at home where it is, out.
Well he loves oral surgery in general.
And in my mind, he like had one
leg up on the dentist chair.
It was like one of them was
so, my roots were twisted--
Oh!
And my head was like,
Ugh! Ugh! Ugh!
Like you know, he was like...
I was having to hold my neck back.
And it makes a popping
sound when it comes out.
I don't recall.
The only way I would do it is if I was
drugged so aggressively.
Okay. This, this next question,
this is a head scratcher.
I think I do have an answer though that,
or at least something that can guide us.
This is from ZylliesServant?
Yeah.
Syd. If a blood donor kills
someone, can the person
who received the murderer's
blood be convicted
of the murder based on DNA evidence?
This is why blood donor
doning is anonymous.
So you can't frame somebody.
Could this happen?
It doesn't matter if it's anonymous,
because let's just say you
just received a bunch of blood
and then you got mad at somebody
or there was just some justifiable reason
that you wanted to kill
somebody and you did it
and in the process you were stabbed
and you bled on the crime scene.
Could the DNA of the blood,
let's just say you got like
a, almost a full blown--
Point the donor?
Transfusion.
Yeah.
So, we're not scientists, I think
that's been made abundantly
clear, but we do know
how to read articles on the internet.
Well, I didn't read any articles.
So go ahead and give me your best guess
and I'll give you some
scientific guidance afterwards.
I think that your, let's see, DNA.
I mean, there's certainly DNA in blood
because it's just a cell.
They all have the DNA.
But to me, it has to, if
you did it immediately,
like you got a huge
freaking blood transfusion.
I would say it would have to be like 90,
over 90% of your blood
would have to be replaced
because I think somehow
you get, so you gotta have,
maybe I'll say 65% of your
blood has to be replaced.
And then--
You're getting very specific,
for non-scientific discourse--
You have to murder somebody within,
I would say an hour.
And boy, that's tough to
get a blood transfusion
and then murder somebody?
Yeah, you're pretty weak at that point.
That would be so bad ass.
But you walk right out of the hospital
and just kill the first person you see.
Or just do it right in the hospital,
kill the person who is giving,
who is saving your life.
There's irony.
Yeah.
But that we're not gonna really need
much of an investigation
if you kill the person
in the hospital that next
to you giving you blood.
That's true, okay.
Well, I'm glad I'm not a criminal.
You know what--
I'm glad you're not a detective.
But I think that your blood
assimilates very quickly.
Foreign blood is accepted
and the DNA is replaced,
or there's just not enough of it.
I think that's what it is.
So--
Has to be quick and it has
to be a big transfusion.
I think you're basically right.
Oh, thank goodness!
Scientific American has this article
from 2009 by Michelle Gong.
Michelle N. Gong, an assistant professor
at the Mount Sinai school
of medicine, explains.
So we've got an assistant professor.
Well, I mean, that doesn't, she's probably
a professor at this point.
Sounds like a TA to me.
Um, so basically I'm not
gonna read this article,
but it seems to be the
case that there's not,
there is DNA in blood and
blood that has been transfused,
but it is almost certainly
going to be overwhelmed
by the DNA of the recipient.
Like, so in the, in the crime scene,
now you're kind of talking about like,
just blood everywhere.
Typically DNA evidence is
like hair, skin cells, saliva.
There's more than just blood, right.
Hm mm.
But even within the blood, and I guess,
if you replaced 90% of your blood,
I don't know what the case is.
But typically if you
just go and receive blood
because you needed a blood transfusion
that did like a certain
percentage of your blood.
It says that donor DNA
and blood transfusions
in the recipients persist
for a number of days,
sometimes longer, but
its presence is unlikely
to alter genetic test significantly.
Basically once you go and you start--
It could happen though.
Analyzing the DNA, the
overwhelming DNA signature
will be from your existing DNA, right.
But literally if that one situation
of where you just basically
are full of donor blood
and it's got the DNA, now
it says something about
transfused blood, red blood
cells, the primary component
in transfusions have
no nucleus and no DNA.
What?
Transfused blood does, however,
host a significant
amount of DNA-containing
white blood cells or leukocytes
around a billion cells
per unit, roughly one pint of blood.
Red blood cells have
no nucleus and no DNA?
So, yeah, so you're not
saying that there is
not a DNA signature there,
but there's gonna be
red blood cells.
You're gonna have some red blood cells.
Are you gonna, there's
gonna be some DNA there
and then yeah, your body
quickly assimilates.
I don't know what that process is like
and how the DNA gets
overwhelmed and replaced.
But I think that the chances
of that particular situation
of somebody getting all their blood,
killing somebody and the
majority of their DNA
being left at the scene
is just more blood.
We probably never had the
opportunity to experiment
with that specific scenario.
I'm sure there's been somebody who's
they've taken like a pint
of blood that's not theirs--
With them?
To frame somebody, but
you gotta, forensically,
you gotta be real smart about that.
But I think you should, I think actually--
The spatter, I've watched enough CSI.
I think you take hair, spit and some skin.
If you really wanna leave
the mark of somebody else,
but getting that from
a person is difficult.
You wanna receive a blood donation,
a hair donation and a skin/spit donation,
and then kill somebody.
If you coordinate this right.
You could do it.
Right, first of all, you got to develop
a relationship with their barber, right?
Yeah.
You can get lots of hair from a barber
and you can come up with all kinds
of semi legitimate reasons
why you would need it.
I'm gonna make a to sweater for my kid.
Did you know that the
most comfortable pillows
are made of human hair?
You don't wanna tell the barber something
that seems like a great business idea.
It needs to be something
personal, not something scalable,
like hair pillows.
Yeah. I wanna do a, one
of a kind hair painting
for that guy who was just in your chair,
who I'm actually framing for murder.
You know I wanna give him a
hair, hair, painting gift.
I believe that this is
one of the scenarios
where you saying exactly the truth.
Like sometimes in movies, like the killer
will say exactly the truth
and it's so outlandish that it just,
nobody takes it seriously.
If you wanna frame this guy for murder,
I'm about to commit
Right.
And they just give you
the hair and you walk out.
Yeah.
So that's easy to get the hair.
Skin? You got to talk to
their, I guess, masseuse?
You gotta talk to their masseuse.
You gotta be like, after
you rubbed this person down,
can I--
your hand?
For science purposes, can I get can I get
a sample of his skin?
This is from your hands.
Aah, spit, that's super easy.
I mean, there's a number of
ways to get people's spit.
You could be like a fake
23andMe kind of service.
Get them to spit in
something, you could be,
you could probably go door to door.
"We're collecting the neighborhood spit."
Yeah, you could--
People will probably give you their spit.
You could just, this is cleaner,
I think the best thing
to do clean their house,
like show up as a cleaner.
Oh, this is good.
For a service free, you get you get
all the cells you want,
of every type, man.
And you could also dust for fingerprints
and then maybe create some sort of--
Freaking Tony Danza.
Okay. That was it.
Okay.
What's the next one?
The next one is also a crime question.
Oh yeah, here we are.
CSI. Don't get fooled again.
Mariah.
I don't see Mariah's handle.
Cause I screenshot this incorrectly.
Mariah though.
If someone is framed,
we're in crime framing.
If someone is framed for a crime
and ends up in prison,
but then they escape.
And while they are on the
run, the police figure out
who really did the crime
and put them away instead,
would the person who wasn't
supposed to be locked up
in the first place have to
go back for escaping prison
or would they just be free
since they technically
weren't supposed to be there anyway.
Well, so if you're, if
you're wrongfully convicted
and imprisoned, you escape.
And then at the same time, exonerated,
Enter Harrison Ford.
I'm not lying. And this was
not a setup for this question.
But me and Shepherd watched,
"The Fugitive" together
like three weeks ago.
I remember that being a good movie.
I watched it basically when it came out.
Like 94 ish, 92.
Early nineties.
One of the things that I
ended up doing quite often,
when I'm trying to figure
out what we're gonna watch
as a family--
I saw a movie.
Oh yeah yeah.
Link has seen this movie,
which is pretty phenomenal.
Okay, there you go, was all I need needed.
I'll look up like top 100
thrillers of all time.
You know, I was like, I
wanna watch an action movie,
a good action movie with Shepherd,
and pulled out "The
Fugitive" and of course,
as it's coming on, first
of all, there's this moment
in every movie that's
made before, like 2004
where kids know, because
the credits are so long
at the beginning of the
movie, they're like,
what is this opening title sequence
for three minutes where
they're telling me everybody
who did everything in the movie.
You can't do that anymore
because people are like,
what the hell is this?
Put that at the end,
I don't care about it.
A lot of movies, they put
the title at the end now.
Yeah, you got no time, you
got to get into it, man.
I'm not a fan of that by the way.
Title at the end?
Not a fan of the title at the end.
I want the title up
front, but I don't need,
I watched the credits.
You know, I'm in LA,
I'm in the industry.
I stick around and I watch the credits
until the movie's done
when I go to a theater.
Long opening sequence to "The Fugitive."
But this is the plot of The Fugitive,
which is a, by the way,
highly recommended movie.
And yes, we are going to spoil it.
But you can imagine if
the setup of the thing
is the guy's wrongfully
convicted for murder.
In this case, the murder of his wife,
you can imagine that he's
going to exonerate himself,
but the movie is basically
about him being a fugitive.
He's being chased by a federal agent
and played by Tommy Lee Jones.
Oh yeah.
At his finest.
Oh yeah?
Well at his Tommy Lee Jones, I mean,
he's just the same guy in every movie
and he's on the run.
And then he's trying
to prove his innocence.
And he has an outlandish story about a guy
with a prosthetic limb
who killed his wife.
It turns out that it's
got some stuff to do
with some pharmaceutical
scheme, et cetera.
But, and also Jane Lynch
makes a cameo before she was,
you know, a household name.
She's like, she works at the hospital.
Anyway, in the movie, and I've based
all my legal opinions off of things
that happen in movies from the 90's.
He never went to prison.
He didn't escape from prison, did he?
Oh yeah, he was.
I thought he escaped--
He was in custody--
On the way or something.
Well, he was in custody,
whether he's in prison or not,
he's in custody.
He's on the inmate bus.
Yes.
And presumably he's already been in,
he's been in cati... he's
been in jail, awaiting trial.
He gets convicted.
He's being transferred to
prison with a bunch of prisoners
in a bus, the bus wrecks.
And he's given the opportunity to escape
and he takes it and then he's on the run.
And then he spends the whole movie
trying to prove himself innocent.
And of course at the--
Spoiler alert!
He was not.
He's totally guilty. No.
So, and at the end of the
movie, when basically, you know,
Tommy Lee Jones, you can kind of tell,
is becoming convinced of his innocence
as the movie is going on.
And so at the end of the
movie, it's kind of like, dude,
I know you like escaped the deal
and we've been running all
over the place--
He can't do it.
You know, you're innocent.
So yeah, go free.
Oh, Tommy Lee Jones did let him go.
Yeah.
I don't remember now.
Yeah. I mean, he's, the implication,
I can't, even though it's
only been three weeks,
I can't remember exactly what happens.
The implication is he's
exonerated himself.
Everybody knows it and
he's not gonna be in prison
and he's not going to
be, this is the thing.
Because in America I went to Quora,
which is like where people
who are sometimes experts
or at least claim to be experts or think
they're experts answer questions.
And the answer to this question was filled
with a bunch of people
saying that at least
in the United States, the
act of escaping confinement
is in itself a crime and often involves
some sort of property damage and maybe
some sort of assault is
required in order to get out.
So, but let's just say that
it's a perfect situation.
You didn't break any laws.
You just looked and all of a sudden,
like the gate at prison was open,
and you just walked out.
Yeah.
You technically committed
a crime when you did that
but in the court of public
opinion, if you're exonerated,
when you're out--
The judge may say, okay, the time served.
Yeah. Right, right.
In some countries--
Especially if the time
you've served is more
than the time that would have
been for a prison escape.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
In some countries I have read,
it is not illegal to escape imprisonment.
I saw that too.
Can that be true?
But the view, it seems
true because I read it
and it was like grammatically correct--
How is that possible though--
But you typically--
Its like saying saying you should escape.
And then I don't know.
The one thing I read was like,
because it's the natural,
you can't punish somebody
for their natural inclination
to wanna not be in prison, but really?
Well I would have a natural inclination--
That's a ridiculous rationale.
But even in those
countries, there's typically
other infractions associated with it
that you can still be convicted for
and put back behind bars
associated with an escape.
And then there was this
one anecdote of this guy,
I think in Germany, where it
is claimed to not be illegal,
to escape, that his
prison outfit showed up
at the prison laundered and folded and,
and consider in a considerate
way, shipped back to them.
So then they didn't have,
he didn't steal the...
Oh, sorry.
Sounds like an urban legend.
Yeah. But I read that.
I have my doubts about
the why that would not
be the law, but I don't know.
I don't, I've never thought about it.
You know, you talk about
exoneration in movies.
Like I think about "The
Hurricane," Denzel Washington.
I definitely wanna see that again.
It's been a long time since I saw that.
That was a good movie.
It's a really good movie. I
gotta watch that one again.
Oh, you know another good movie.
This is along the same
lines of that, "Just Mercy."
I watched that recently--
Oh, new movie?
Michael B. Jordan, but
again, based on a true story,
like a young attorney trying
to to prove a guy innocent
and the guy still still
to this day operates
this institution that is basically like
the Innocence Project kind of thing,
but offering legal--
Yeah, I was gonna mention
the Innocence Project
because once you start thinking about just
the horrifying reality of
being falsely imprisoned,
it was one guy who was
in prison for 37 years
and then exonerated.
You know--
For a rape he didn't commit.
I have an incredible story.
It wasn't planning on telling,
but my dad told me this.
I was talking, I was
talking to my dad who,
up until this year, he retired.
He was a law professor.
And of course he was a lawyer
before he was a law professor.
And I was talking to him
about how much I enjoyed
"Just Mercy" which is the story
again, of a young attorney,
a young black attorney
going down to Alabama
and trying to prove, like sorta re-examine
the evidence around this black guy
who was falsely accused of
murdering a white woman.
And it takes place in like,
that "Just Mercy" takes place
in like the eighties or
nineties, early nineties I think.
Then as you can imagine, the
guy was wrongfully convicted.
I was telling my dad about it.
If they're gonna make a
movie about it, then, yeah.
He starts telling me a
story, I'm like, why have you
never told me this story before?
So when my dad was a very new attorney,
like had just graduated
from, from law school
and like just got, just passed the bar.
Hm mm?
At that point, you kind of assigned cases.
And so there's a, there's a
guy, in, who is a security guard
at the Smithsonian in Washington, DC.
Okay?
And like, whatever year this is, you know,
my dad's beginning to practice law.
So early seventies.
And he a guy breaks into the Smithsonian
and he has to shoot him and kill him.
Wow.
And as they're kind of, now, he's innocent
for shooting the dude, but in the process
of examining who this guy is,
this guy is a prison escapee--
The security guard?
The security guard, this guy escaped
from an Alabama, no, I
guess it was Georgia,
from a Georgia chain gang.
In like 1940, also like 30 years ago.
Right.
And he was convicted of some crime.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know what the
crime was, he was convicted
of a serious crime, a felony.
And then he was on the chain gang
and he escaped from the
chain gang and then goes on
to live a normal life.
But they find, oh, this guy
is fricking from a chain gang.
And so they assigned the case to my dad--
To defend him?
My dad to defend him.
Oh wow.
And my dad sits down with him.
And basically this guy went on to live
a completely fruitful life
contributing to a society.
And also by the way, cause
he, my dad asked him flat out.
Did you do the thing that
you were convicted of?
He's like, no.
And he said, "I didn't
even have the opportunity
to enter a plea."
And so my dad's like,
okay, yeah, Georgia 1940.
I can imagine that this is the way it was.
So my dad starts looking at
the documents, the records.
And he finds that there is
a guy who, some position
in the court who was
overseeing like an attorney
who was overseeing
these cases at the time,
who is still alive and who
is now like 90 years old
and lives somewhere in Georgia.
And my dad goes to the
dude's house, which is crazy.
Cause this is kind of what
happens in "Just Mercy."
Where like you go to these people who have
something to do with the case, of course.
And "Just Mercy" is just,
a decade ago or whatever,
but this is like decades ago.
And he sits down with
this guy and he says,
this is my client and
this is what happened.
Do you remember this
case? And he was like,
"I don't remember the
details of that case,
but I'll tell you the way
that it used to be work."
He said, "Every Monday morning,
everybody that we had arrested,
he said every black person
that we had arrested--"
Okay.
"We'd bring then into
court. And we would enter
a guilty plea for all of them."
Everyone he says would not give them
an opportunity to testify.
We're not giving them an
opportunity to even enter a plea.
They would represent
them all as a collective,
regardless of what had happened,
whatever they've been arrested for,
just enter a guilty plea
and then sentence them.
Systemic racism. It's real.
So there's no trial,
it's just a conviction.
It's just a sentencing?
He. So he's like, well, we
obviously this is wrong.
And so my dad like takes this.
I don't know exactly what he did,
but he basically takes
this evidence to this thing
and the judge says, "All right,
this was a wrongful
conviction. And he's free,
but then it it's appealed,
or they have to take it
to the district court,
which was in New Orleans.
And my dad is, you know--
He's green.
He's green, he's already
received his 500 bucks
or whatever you get to,
to represent somebody.
And you're not supposed
to receive anymore.
He's like, do you want
me to go to New Orleans
and defend this guy?
And the judge was like, yep.
And we'll make sure that you, you know,
we pay for your expenses or whatever.
He didn't have any money.
So he goes down there and
basically presents the case
to a, just a big court.
A district court is
just a bunch of judges,
like overseeing a bunch of cases, right.
And they let the dude go.
Dang, that that needs to be a movie, man.
I was like, Dad, I was like, dad, this is
basically "Just Mercy."
Why have you never told me this story?
The interesting thing
about it is that the guy,
I mean after decades, maybe
there's not as much fear,
but there's still got to be this thing.
I could, I haven't been
caught, but I could have,
I could have been found out
and it could still happen.
And I'm a security guard and
I'm doing everything right.
But then he's presented
with this opportunity.
I mean, to do his job
requires shooting somebody
in the Smithsonian or
not, by the way he didn't,
and at that moment, he,
it sounds like he did
the right thing where that put him in,
in danger of scrutiny
that then it came to pass,
you know, so doing the
right thing, put him
in the cross-hairs of
going back to prison.
Yeah.
Man!
Well I think the thing that
"Just Mercy" highlights
is that, okay, yes, because
of the civil rights movement,
things have gotten better
that that exact scenario
doesn't happen anymore.
But the fact is, is that the
roots of that systemic racism
are still very alive and well,
and they continue to be cut back.
They continue to be rooted out literally.
And, but, you know, as
recently as the early nineties,
it was all basically almost
exactly the same scenario,
but just with one individual
guy and then this stuff is
still, there's still
a lot of this existing
in sentencing and, it still exists.
It's like, if you, in any
sort of nonpartisan evaluation
of the current justice system
shows that there is still
a bunch of inconsistencies
and a bunch of injustice
towards people of color.
You should--
Still around.
And that's why BLM exists.
Yeah.
But by the way.
You should get some more stories
from your, from your dad.
You should.
Well, he's got a really good one
that I think I've told before about the,
being attacked by some,
some female inmates
who escaped from a place
that he was working.
He got, they teamed up
on him and beat him up
and got out, like two or
three female prisoners. Yeah.
He's got a good story about that too.
Were they innocent?
Did he exonerate them after the fact?
He represented them after the fact.
We got to do, we could do,
we could do a crime podcast.
We kind of did.
Like a whole different, a new podcast.
You could just turn this
into a crime podcast--
Crime Biscuits.
Yeah!
Hmm.
Ha, ha!
Well, hopefully you'll sleep
a little better at night.
Some of you.
Yeah. And we, you know what, there's many
more questions that we didn't get to.
So we'll do this again.
This was a fun conversation.
Led to some really interesting
places, you know what?
I wasn't gonna make this, my rec,
but I am going to make it
now that I talked about it,
"Just Mercy," the movie,
it's super well done.
First of all, you got
Jamie Fox playing the guy
who was convicted.
You got Michael B. Jordan
playing the attorney,
really great performances.
And I just think it's one of those things
that I think it's important to,
especially if you question
whether or not this,
the systemic racism that people
talk about actually exist.
And based on some of the stuff
that I see on the internet,
a large percentage of
people, at least in America,
continue to question whether
or not this is even a reality.
They think this is just
some trumped up bullshit.
That's trying to support
some kind of Marxist movement
or whatever latest conspiracy
theory is about it.
When the reality is, is
there's a lot of injustice
has been done.
And this movie does a great job.
It's just a great movie is a great story.
And it does a really
good job of highlighting
exactly how frustrating it
would be to be a black person
in the justice system,
especially at that juncture,
in that place in the
deep, deep South Alabama.
So "Just Mercy," watch it. It's good.
And if you wanna go back a few decades,
"The Hurricane" is a similar story.
Yeah.
All right.
# Ear Biscuits.
Let's continue the conversation.
Let us know what you think.
And then we'll speak
at you again next week,
because that's what we do.
We want to, we enjoy it.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical Best.